la réunion du forum du dialogue
politique libyen prévu sur cinq jours a
commencé lundi 1er février dans un lieu
tenu secret autour de genève dès son
ouverture la représentante des nations
unies a exhorté les participants à
confirmer l'issue démocratique du
processus
vous avez a posé une marque indélébile
sur le calendrier pour la tenue
d'élections nationales le 24 décembre de
cette année celle date pour une élection
à la fin de l'année a été décidée lors
d'un précédent round des pourparlers au
maroc en novembre dernier
l'enjeu de cette semaine de discussions
et de désigner un conseil présidentiel
composé de trois membres ainsi qu'un
premier ministre un gouvernement unifié
de transition qui aura pour mission
d'organiser le scrutin depuis la révolte
de 2011 et l'intervention de l'otan qui
a précipité la chute de kadhafi la libye
est profondément divisé à l'ouest le
gouvernement reconnu par l'onu
le gn à halle est la plus grande zone du
pays contrôlé par l'armée nationale
libyenne du maréchal haftar d'abord alia
kadhafi puis opposant depuis la fin des
années 1980 ce militaire s'est engagé en
2011 pour la chute du gouvernement et
enfin au sud nous ont très peu densément
peuplées contrôlée par les tribus du sud
des milices qui se divise entre les deux
camps
c'est donc dans ce contexte que le forum
du dialogue politique libyen a déjà
présélectionné 45 candidats parmi
lesquels il faudra choisir les quatre
personnes qui constitueront l'exécutif
libyen jusqu'au vote du 24 décembre
prochain